[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour heureux de vous retrouver pour
ce nouveau 7,8 le journal voici les
titres
cet après midi les nouveaux députés se
sont réunis pour la première séance
publique au palais bourbon nos
journalistes nicolas d'andry mélanie
pocket sont sur place pour le détailler
cette journée plus propre plus pratique
et plus écologique le but 100%
électrique devient une réalité en ile de
france notamment à versailles où un
nouvel équipement va bientôt rouler sur
la ligne 23 du réseau kéolis entre
versailles et vélizy villacoublay puis
notre propre très du jour est dédié à
mustapha larbaoui l'homme est surtout
connu pour avoir avoir été le président
de l'étoile sportive de trappes pendant
14 ans sous son impulsion le club de
football des pages chaque année les 1000
naissances ir l'on débute ce journal
avec les premiers pas de nos députés
yvelinois cet après-midi les 577 se sont
réunis pour la première séance publique
au palais bourbon
sur place on retrouve nicolas d'andré
mélanie poker alors nicolas
les députés ont dû élire aujourd'hui le
nouveau président de l'assemblée
nationale ce sera effectivement aux
semaines et les députés ont élu françois
de rugy président de l'assemblée
nationale il a obtenu 353 voix
durant cette séance d'ouverture de la
15e législature nous avons pu voir les
députés yves binois voter un moment
qu'ils ont qualifié de solennel certains
d'entre eux connaissent déjà leurs
commissions parlementaires or berger
siègera dans la commission éducation et
culture jean noël barrot se penchera sur
les questions budgétaires en intégrant
la commission des finances
enfin le député pour un autre exemple le
député yvelinois du modem bruno myle yen
se penchera sur les questions du
développement durable et de
l'aménagement du territoire
les premières réunions en connu en
commission devrait avoir lieu demain
matin avant l'installation du bureau de
l'assemblée nationale dans l'après midi
merci
nicolas dandrieu on passe à une page
plutôt éducation à la rentrée 2010 est
des étudiants ingénieurs dans
l'université de l'université pierre
marie curie de jussieu vont pouvoir
profiter d'une nouvelle plate forme
d'ingénierie expérimental à saint cyr
l'école de nouveaux bâtiments pour plus
d'expérience et de travaux pratiques
visite des lieux avec stéphane servant
dans un cadre exceptionnel les nouveaux
étudiants ingénieurs de l'université
pierre et marie curie vont avoir accès à
la rentrée prochaine à de nouveaux
bâtiments installés à saint cyr l'école
une plate forme d'ingénierie
expérimental pour réaliser des
expériences et des travaux de recherche
les métiers sont des métiers autour de
l'ingénierie 1 principalement on va les
retrouver dans des grands grands grande
industrie de l'automobile de
l'aéronautique du calcul du service les
étudiants pourront analyser avec une
soufflerie les forces qui s'exercent sur
les ailes d'un avion ils simuleront les
vibrations d'un immeuble en cas de
séisme
ils auront aussi accès à cette chambre
électromagnétiques où on peut analyser
les ondes émises par les téléphones
une pièce que peu d'universités possède
l'objectif est de reconstituer ce qu'on
appelle un environnement de référence
qui serait l'environnement des espaces
libres celui qu'on pourrait avoir si on
était
au milieu de l'espace avec absolument
aucun perturbateurs électromagnétiques
environnants certains s'orienteront vers
la robotique sur roues ou dans l'eau
avec ses mini sous marin capable de
s'orienter uniquement grâce à leur sonar
des robots guide et que l'on trouve déjà
sur de nombreux sites industriels
ça permet de savoir utiliser un sonar de
bien savoir comment la crise tic marche
enfin parmi toutes les matières étudiées
les énergies propres et renouvelables
comme les panneaux solaires où l'on va
pouvoir mesurer les performances des
panneaux photovoltaïques sur une vraie
maison un site modernisé qui va
conforter la place de première
université française dans les domaines
de l'ingénierie la technologie et les
sciences informatiques
l'upm se hisse à la 4e place européenne
et à la 32e mondial
plus propre plus pratique et plus
écologique le but 100% électrique
devient une réalité à versailles un
nouvel équipement va bientôt rouler sur
la ligne 23 du réseau kéolis entre
versailles et vélizy villacoublay
l'initiative s'inscrit dans le cadre du
grand paris des bus qui doit permettre
de renouveler 30% du réseau francilien
d'ici 2020 une première discrète et sans
pollution voici le bus 100 % électrique
à petit ce dès le mois de septembre les
voyageurs de la ligne 23 du réseau fébus
pourront emprunter ce véhicule innovant
entre les villes de versailles et vélizy
villacoublay
conçu par le spécialiste des transports
la société alstom s'est inspiré pour ce
prototype du modèle parisien des
tramways on a un concept quand je dis
tramway sur pneus c'est parce que vous
avez une structure mécanique qui nous
permet déjà d'installer tous les
équipements en toiture et pas d'en avoir
à la fois dans le flux sous le châssis
on a également 25 % de surfaces vitrées
en plus par rapport à un bus
conventionnel
on retrouvait là aussi un petit peu
l'image du tramway et puis vous voyez
par pia trois portent donc trois portes
aujourd'hui tramway donc une meilleure
accessibilité puis surtout des des
portes qui sont beaucoup plus robuste
que des portes de bus lancé en 2016 par
le syndicat des transports
d'ile-de-france les bus électriques
rentrer ici dans une nouvelle phase avec
au total six lignes équipées en région
cette nouvelle génération de bus plus
écologique et plus confortables doit
permettre aussi de rendre attractif les
transports en commun pour les
franciliens pour décider les habitants
de la grande couronne à ne pas prendre
leur voiture
il leur faut des transports en commun
qui soit attractive ça veut dire avec
l'air conditionné
ça veut dire avec de l'info voyageurs ça
veut dire totalement accessible quand on
a des enfants des poussettes ça veut
dire ça veut dire un autre bus et pour
les habitants de la grande couronne
c'est aussi important d'avoir des bus
silencieux et non polluant la région
ile-de-france est fixé comme ambition de
rendre propre 30% de sa flotte de bus et
de cars d'ici 2020 le salon du bourget
c'est le rendez vous des industriels de
l'aviation et de l'aérospatiale
mais c'est aussi une grande fête 180
mille visiteurs dont en effet sillonné
les allées des stands et foulé le tarmac
l'occasion de voir de près la centaine
d'appareils comme ces avions champion du
monde de voltige aérienne de l'aéro club
de saint cyr l'école reportage stéphane
servant
moment très attendu de ce salon du
bourget les démonstrations en vol et
particulièrement la voltige aérienne
le public nombreux a pu admirer la
patrouille de france mais également ses
petits avions des caps 10 basée à saint
cyr l'école sur le terrain de l'aéro
club
ils appartiennent à laval amicale de
voltige aérienne qui a formé de nombreux
pilotes
le club possède plusieurs modèles
monoplace ou biplace et comprend une
centaine de membres à sa tête
régis alajouanine qui a créé le club il
ya 37 ans c'est une légende de
l'aviation qui fabriquent tous ses
avions
l'amicale de voltige aérienne j'ai créé
en 1980 sa fête à 37 ans a autour la
cape disent qu'on a toujours avec notre
avion fétiche et depuis bas avec toute
l'équipe de bénévoles que j'ai on a fait
tout un chose on a reperdu au cap de
revoler après un accident
on a fait des modifications on a fait
évoluer les câbles et on ait des avions
qui sont champions du lion du monde avec
des champions et des championnes comme
code le mordant qui est encore
championne du monde qui a été championne
du monde au texas avec notre cap de 332
démonstration avec ce cap 432 véritable
formule un désert qui participent au
championnat du monde de voltige aérienne
le pilote atteint la vitesse de 405 km
heure avec des accélérations de plus ou
moins 9 g soit neuf fois le poids de son
corps à son bord benoît mériaux un
pilote d'exception
ingénieur chez dassault aviation il faut
aimer se concentrer il faut aimer
des sensations assez forte faire un
certain physique aujourd'hui la
particularité c'est elle à très haute
température on va dire il faut aimer la
rigueur et il faut aimer se remettre en
question ce qui est parfois très
difficile pour l'ego le pilote très
concentré se focalise sur les figures
maintes fois répété il enchaîne les
tonneaux et les figures c'était aussi la
première démonstration en vol pour
dorine bourneton régis alajouanine a
modifié un avion pour que cette jeune
femme paraplégique à la suite d'un
accident d'avion à l'âge de 16 ans
puissent à nouveau évoluer seul dans les
airs
j'ai commencé la formation de voltige ya
deux ans à peu près
et aujourd'hui j'ai atteint un deuxième
cycle de voltige et à ce titre j'ai pu
faire une démonstration
voltige ici au bourget parce que je suis
la première femme handicapée au monde
pilotes de voltige
grâce à ces modifications techniques des
commandes manuelles à la main elle peut
piloter le premier avion équipé pour une
personne handicapée
je suis super fier parce qu'après avoir
un accident d'avion à l'âge de 16 ans
c'est une belle revanche
on passe maintenant aux sports le
saviez-vous disney et la fédération
française de judo ont fait un
partenariat le but encourager la
pratique du sport de cette association
est née le 10 mai challenge
cela s'est déroulé le week end dernier
au vélodrome plus de 500 enfants âgés
entre 7 et 11 ans ont participé à cet
événement qu avait pour but de les
initier au judo aujourd'hui dans notre
portrait du jour coup de projecteur sur
mustapha larbaoui pharmacien de
profession l'homme est surtout connu
aujourd'hui pour avoir été le président
de l'étoile sportive de trappes pendant
14 ans sous son impulsion le club de
football a dépassé chaque année les
mille licenciés le portrait de mustapha
là-bas hui écrit par michael et nous
hydro
c'est l'histoire d'un homme qui vit à
100 à l'heure entre son travail de
pharmaciens les terrains de football
mustapha larbaoui 56 ans mène une double
vie professionnelle de passion qui
s'emboîtent dans un emploi du temps
surchargé président du club de l'étoile
sportive l'homme né à versailles géré
aussi depuis 2007 la pharmacie
principale située rue jean jaurès à
trappes
c'est le football qui manage cette
pharmacie
lorsque j'ai repris le club de foot il
m'avait semblé que il serait bon de
rester sur le secteur parce que j'ai
besoin d'être présents physiquement sur
les terrains donc j'ai pu allier les
deux quand j'avais une heure par ci par
là je l'a consacré au foot
aller et on dit bonjour détection il ya
la télé il a tout le monde aujourd'hui
ça va c'est bien ça fr vous savez faire
le hockey entraînements matchs rencontre
avec les éducateurs le dirigeant pas 7
jours sur 7 sur les terrains de football
depuis sa prise de fonction en 2003 pas
de place pour les loisirs le week end le
samedi c'est le platon matin
l'engagement des enfants est totale
elles font dans l' envie de gagner
l'envi des perfectible mais on parle
envie de performer
donc on a forcément des échos le samedi
après midi c'est pareil le dimanche
toute la journée que les vétérans le
matin moi je suis connecté en permanence
c'est facile il ya des outils pour ça
mais d'abord je me déplace beaucoup
surtout à l'extérieur
et puis après on est connecté le
portable les messages les résultats je
les ai tout de suite
mustapha larbaoui a également créé en
2015 une section de football féminin qui
compte aujourd'hui 92 en dehors des
terrains l'académie a vu le jour ce
renforcement scolaire permet à des
jeunes du club ont cm2 d'avoir des cours
de mathématiques et de français
trois classes de 15 élèves se sont
ouvertes depuis deux ans moi je suis
qu'un acteur dans la chaîne éducative où
j'ai vraiment le sentiment que pour pas
employer de grands mots on transmet de
véritables valeurs non présidents de
club qui fait passer des messages
une structure qui organise mais en même
temps qu'ils vivent au quotidien son
planning devrait s'alléger dans les
prochaines semaines après 14 années
passées à la tête du club mustapha a
décidé de raccrocher les crampons ce
mois ci j'ai souhaité m'arrêter cette
année c'est parce que j'ai toujours eu
cette l'idée qu' il fallait jamais assez
très longtemps surtout trop longtemps
cantonné dans un tourbillon comme celui
que je vis professionnels associatifs et
personnel on se rend compte que les
choses vont vite ce que j'aime et en
même temps il ya des choses qu'on
risquerait de laisser passer et
je voudrais surtout pas passer à côté
sans fond de choses importantes mustapha
larfaoui restera président d'honneur de
trappes est responsable de sa pharmacie
avant d'envisager d'autres projets qui
le mèneront peut-être vingt autres
tourbillon la politique c'est la fin de
ce 7 8 le journal merci de nous avoir
suivis et surtout bonne soirée
[Musique]